Ukraine celebrates retaking Herson it's
one of the most significant victories
since Basha invaded is this a turning
point in the war and how might it change
military strategies on both sides this
is Inside Story
[Music]
hello welcome to the program I'm Hashem
Russia has pulled out of the only major
city it captured in nearly nine months
of war in Ukraine croissant fell in
early March a week after the invasion
began but Ukrainian forces have made
rapid advances in the last few weeks
[Applause]
people in this city cheered and raised
the Ukrainian flag on public buildings
President Vladimir Putin formerly Annex
the region in September in a move
condemned internationally as
spokesmanian says that Kremlin will
still recognize her son as part of
Russia but Ukraine's President says the
region is back in Ukrainian hands
calling it a historic day
they've never given up in Ukraine hope
for Ukraine is always Justified and
Ukraine always returns its own
I want to make a special mention of
those Russian soldiers mercenaries and
collaborators who were abandoned in
Hassan and other cities of the South the
only chance of being saved is to
surrender to Ukrainian captivity we
guarantee that you will be treated in
accordance with the law and
international standards
Russia called the pull out a
redeployment videos showed Bridges
leading out of the city destroyed Moscow
says 30 000 soldiers and five thousand
pieces of military equipment have been
moved to the east of the Nipper River
Ukrainian leaders believe Russian troops
Left Behind land mines and won't
Harrison could come under Russian
shelling
foreign
the security studies program director
with the Ukrainian prism that's the
Ukrainian foreign policy and security
Think Tank it must call Pavel
fingenhauer an independent defense and
Military analyst and Economist in London
senior lecturer in security and
development at King's College London and
specialists in Bashan foreign and
security policy welcome to the program
Hana how significant is the recaptural
her song by the Ukrainian Army
there are two elements that we need to
understand first is strategic and that
is definitely important because that is
part of the course and that is access to
Crimea so that is important town on the
south from all perspectives and
especially if the Ukrainian forces will
advance further but it's also extremely
important psychologically because uh
first of all it was the only big city
the only Regional Center that Russians
managed to capture since the beginning
of this wave of invasion but also
because Russia just Incorporated and
said that it is Russian city part of the
Russian history it is Russian Empire and
all those propaganda that were heard
within the last nine months and that's
why now it's really interesting to
follow Russian social networks how the
loopholes are starting to question if
we've been defending the Russian
population there why they're greeting
Ukrainian Armed Forces with all these
happiness and Ukrainian Flags so we
think that psychologically it will be
important both for the Ukrainian as it
is important to liberate your people but
also as The Leverage against the Russian
propaganda inside this Russia Pavel what
has been described as a major victory by
the ukrainians has been somehow
characterized by the Russians as a
tactical
withdrawal but I think there's a general
consensus that this is a major setback
for the political establishment in
Moscow
uh well the move makes a direct military
sense
but politically yes that there's a
disaster a public Croatian disaster
inside Russia and also it has high
strategic
meaning because by abandoning this
Bridgehead on the right banks of the
nepro river Russia has clearly abandoned
the idea that was in the beginning of
this whole campaign to move further
south and west to take Nicolas Desa
reach the Nestor Republic crevoy Rogue
kind of take over the south of Ukraine
with a more predominantly
russian-speaking regions and cut Ukraine
away from the sea entirely so that dream
has been abandoned the Russian forces
are retreating yes regrouping they're
not that they're directly pushed out but
they are retreating under orders uh in a
more or less organized manner but still
this is a strategic defeat and this is
an internal and to some extent external
political disaster
are we likely to see more of a reset of
strategies or
more escalation in the conflict
I I think that we can expect that maybe
there is more intense fighting on other
fronts uh we have seen that there is now
a very very intense fighting going on
around Bahamut the city is uh very much
sort of Under Siege ukrainians are
fighting very intensely there and over
the last few weeks they've really
suffered many casualties but they've
managed to sort of hold on so it seems
that Russia might decide to hit harder
in other regions of the front especially
in the in the donbass area so I think
that we cannot think that this is now
sort of uh over uh but I think at the
same time there might be some pressures
to to see if Russia can sort of Ensure a
ceasefire that secures its uh its
conquests or which it already has so I
wouldn't be surprised if they are sort
of behind the scenes influence to see if
Russia can secure the regions it already
controls but I would expect an increase
in fighting on other fronts
Hannah emboldened by what happened on
the ground Ukrainian President Vladimir
zielinski vowed that the fight will
continue until the end do you think that
he has all it takes now to continue the
push but all that ultimately other
considerations will have to be taken
before he moves forward
so well what you need to move forward
that is
will and ready
to have these willingness uh yes the
retired nurse yes it is the
understanding of the difficult
conditions during the winter but at the
same time we understand that ceasefire
will play into the hands of the Russian
Federation but not in Ukrainian hands
because that will allow Russians to
train their newly mobilized or to
restore some of their ammunition
stockpile that being destroyed either by
the Iranian or by North Korean or
produced in Russia missiles that is
dangerous for sure so nobody is relaxing
uh what can be the constraints in case
Ukraine has a less supply of the
ammunition from our partners definitely
that can slow down a little bit but
that's also depends on the type of the
Warfare uh we will be witnessing uh
further as for now we understand that
not only bakmut about which the Nutella
just spoke is one of the mere topics but
definitely military and the energy
Nuclear Station and what is interesting
that on the one hand Russians
intensified shelling I am now in the
need of the air raid even in Odessa but
at the same time in Milito we see how
they intensified withdrawal of looted uh
uh good so they also feel very unsafe at
the occupied territories
Pavel after the Russian military pulled
out from cave and harkev the only
provincial original capital under their
control was was her son and then just a
few weeks ago president of Vladimir
Putin announced the annexation of the
forbidian luhans
doniasia now they lost her son
could this be an indication that there
is something terribly wrong with the way
the Russian military establishment has
been thinking about this whole military
Enterprise
uh will this campaign has gone very
wrong for Russia that's an obvious
understood very much in Moscow and there
has been well uh pushing around of the
buck happening because not a military
establishment now sends out well some to
those people who they trust that they
were always against this campaign that
it was pressed on them from the Kremlin
that there were other like we call
hypotenses the secretary of the security
Council and Mr bortnikov from the FSB
Security Agency they were pressing for
this entire campaign the military were
reluctant and because it's clear that
things are gone wrong
and right now Russia Korea really wants
us inspired that's what the Russian
foreign Ministry is saying that's what
Russian diplomats the Kremlin is
indicating a ceasefire along ceasefire
uh uh ceasefire based basically Russia
would want on the status quo who holds
what more or less that's the line of
control a new kind of Minsk because
Russia needs a pause and uh because
Ukraine has quite a number of advantages
and they will be pressing forward they
are offensive especially in the winter
comes and the the frost freezes the dirt
right now covering the entire region and
there's very little good roads there at
all but when the frost comes it will
move again through fields and through
dirt roads and there could be a big
gradient offensive
and Russians are building right now
defense lines in their rear in in Crimea
in anticipation and Gathering reserves
moving out of your Zone to have reserves
for a possible
Ukrainian decisive offensive when the
Russian presidential spokesperson Pascal
says that nothing has has changed as far
as the Russians are concerned in the
sense that herzl remains part of the
country is this more just of an attempt
to contain the crisis uh that has
happened or that the Russians remain
adamant about the need to maintain the
gains they have made in the past
I think that the internal front is
probably the most challenging now for
for Putin because uh it's very difficult
for the Russian public to sort of accept
that these areas that were annexed and
were seen as part of Russia you know
have to be accepted as lost so when I
was listening to sort of TV programs
yesterday it was clear that uh a lot of
the commentary uh of sort of this state
TV run channels you know commentators
were sort of hoping that this was just a
temporary Retreat and that sooner or
later they would take back these areas
so I think it's it's going to be very
challenging for the population to accept
uh that these areas are gone for good
and I think that there's going to be a
lot of work that will have to be done
from sort of the leadership to explain
that maybe this will have to be
postponed for a very long time I think
the narrative has really gripped the
population and especially those who are
in charge of sort of of of of building
opinions inside Russia that this is
really Russian territory and I think
that you know the voices that could have
challenged these views have have are
finding it very difficult many have left
so there isn't really a very open
discussion and those who really are are
sort of challenging the position are
even more assertive in terms of wanting
Russia to to win this war and to
continue this fight so my impression is
that there is a perception that maybe
Russia now needs to regroup forces wait
for the ninja and then re-attack again
in the spring and one of the tactics
that is also sort of being promoted is
this idea of sort of bombing a Ukraine
uh to a complete blackout from the point
of view of its an energy capability
electricity gas so that it is in a
position where it's economic cannot
function its people cannot live properly
so this massive bombardment you know
continue to demoralize in some way the
ukrainians but this as we know hasn't
had any effect so I think we can also
expect these kind of approaches uh you
know to show that you know we're not
giving up with
all right Hannah are we is the next
logical destination of the conflict
going to be centered around zarapujia
all the way towards militopol
uh sooretically yes definitely we
understand that now it is extremely
important to divide uh the Russian tree
between the uh eastern northern and the
Eastern Southern uh directions because
that's also the question of their supply
to some of the forces and after the uh
partial destroyal of the cranian bridge
it is becoming more and more difficult
to supply uh their forces on the south
uh still it is happening but that also
will depend on many other
um issues including the weather uh
because Ukrainian territory is so big
that the weather can be very uh
different from the north to the south
from the almost subtropical to the snow
already in October that's why that will
influence uh the battle on the ground
but also the Russian mistakes are
influencing a lot who are the generals
who are on the ground what decisions
they're going uh to make uh what type of
the artillery they will be using and uh
what the Nutella said about targeting
critical infrastructure trying to make
the blackout that's the tactic that is
definitely expected from the Russian
side for the next tweets because here
they realize that they still have a
certain advancement uh compared to us
but as soon as it is on the ground
that's really interesting how this
regrouping uh been happening uh they
left that much of ammunition including
helicopters so that's quite a difficult
to present as an organized uh withdrawal
from the territories we still have
plenty of soldiers who just change to
civilians and you understand that as
more of these pictures we are sending to
the Russian publics it's also bringing a
certain Panic among the uh um forces
because they don't understand what is
the reason for fighting what commanders
are wanting from them and that's also
these psychological things can have the
snowfall uh effect
probably were earlier talking about the
the Russian military strategy now after
the loss of Carson are we likely to see
them putting more emphasis on on on
gaining places like savatovi the
northeastern of Ukraine or moving all
the way towards zoniask region to try to
consolidate gains in Bahamut and
pavlivka
well Bachman is under siege um uh the
attacks on both motorbed by the chair
car Wagner
mercenary group
um will they take the city or not again
that's an open question but this is a
very tactical move to improve the
positions because right now in the time
of the rasputitsa that's the Sea of mud
you can fight
but maneuverable Swift offensives are
very much hampered by the weather that
will change soon and there the winter
Campaign which you in the west
militaries tend to go to Winter quarters
in the winter but not here not in Russia
Ukraine there's going to be a decisive
military campaign both sides will be
trying to achieve decisive results
Russian strategy right now apparently is
to stop the Ukrainian offensive include
inflict heavy casualties and force
Ukraine and its backers in the west to
go for a provoked ceasefire because
right now Victory as it was envisaged
last February is query unachievable for
that's understood in Moscow so that
right now the Russia would want a pause
in the fighting to regroup really to
rearm your prepare for the future okay
and Ukraine does not want to do that of
course
all right domatella now when you have
the Autumn with all the problems that
come along with with the weather you
have the brains you have the muddy
ground and you have both parties losing
each about a hundred thousand casualties
since the start of the conflict could
this be
the moment for both parties to consider
the need to start political talks
I think this is not going to happen
because I think that um you know from
the Ukrainian perspective it doesn't
make much sense now to sort of negotiate
a ceasefire when they are in a position
of strength they are gaining momentum uh
they are receiving additional equipment
they can hit uh you know uh because they
have advanced they can hit further deep
into the territory that is occupied by
Russia which is forcing Russia to move
some of its uh some control centers
further south uh they have a very strong
morale they are being received you know
by their populations as saviors so this
will really sort of uh I embolden even
more uh you know the Ukrainian
leadership to continue with this
campaign uh and to and to you know to
see if they can make sure that they gain
additional territory because this also
gives them the support externally you
know the more they win the more they can
show to the Western partners that the
military support they're getting you
know has about us producing results and
you know I think the underlying question
of the problem with negotiations is that
there is a very strong lack of trust you
know I think that zilinsky you know for
very obvious reason really doesn't trust
is negotiating partner on the other side
and the Russians as was mentioned by
Pavel are very eager to negotiate but I
think that everyone knows that this will
be just a ceasefire or a preparation for
future fighting uh not a sort of a
definitive agreement for the future so
the only thing that one you hope that
the negotiations would lead to a real
withdrawal of these areas that are
occupied by Russia but I really don't
see okay putting you know going along
that line because already the loss of
hearthstone is causing so much you know
turmoil internally imagine if he had to
withdraw from a lot more territory so
I'm not very optimistic about any kind
of negotiation
it seems obvious that now with the
Euphoria in Ukraine people don't want
this to settle into some sort of
military stalemate they want to continue
the offensive but they know that to do
that they need more weapons
but with the administration the Biden
Administration divided about how to move
forward with
key members of the military
establishment saying it's about time to
start political talks do you think that
this is something that could determine
the next step of the Ukrainian president
you know first of all I can't say there
is a Fourier a foray is for One Day
celebrating deliberation of your people
but in general this Euphoria is very
constrained because people really
understand what are the costs of these
victories and what can be the
consequences and that's what you really
feel among the politicians and among the
society but in terms of the weapons
Supply we just received additional uh
promises just yesterday the new package
being announced not only the us because
U.S is only one country that is
supplying there are other countries and
more countries joining the next week we
will have the new Ramstein group meeting
discussing additional support for
Ukraine we are changing the priorities
of what we need now is more accent for
the air defense systems for example so
that is the ongoing process and
definitely our victories on the ground
make some countries
um look uh differently what to supply to
us it's not only victories but also how
we use these weapons how effectively and
that we are not attacking the Russian
territory but only liberating or
defending ours and regarding the
negotiations it's not about pushing or
not pushing you let's remember that in
March Ukrainian delegation had been
present to the series of negotiations
first in Belarus sedan in Istanbul and
at that time I they were just ultimatums
from the Russian side what is
interesting that after nine months after
all those losses around kievancy now in
person their rhetoric uh is not changing
it is becoming even more violent against
ukrainians so that is why it's not only
a trust but also just the rational about
okay why we are sitting for the
negotiation just to listen how uh
Russians would like to eliminate
Ukrainian Nation they just don't have
any nonsense because the Russian
positions uh didn't change Pavel if the
two parties
automating the future to start
negotiations give us a sense of where do
the Russians stand
as we speak what would be the breadline
for them and what would be the consensus
as far as they are concerned to turn the
chapter of what happened in Ukraine
excited the don't bus the parochia
her son
um that will not change at all uh at
least well the same there's the same
regime in Moscow but there can be kind
of nuances if we were talking about a
ceasefire well Ukraine does not
recognize Crimea as Russian and no one
else does so and but Russia would say
okay you don't recognize this but we
hold it but we don't you know we don't
we recognize that your son as Russia but
you don't and we don't hold it so there
could be a quick pro quo of areas a kind
of agreements tacit agreements of who
holds what for the time being because uh
a peace agreement an actual peace
peace agreement now is untenable but a
ceasefire of sorts can appear the metal
available if you don't mind do you think
diplomacy still stands a chance
I'm not very optimistic as I said for
all the reasons that were also
highlighted by the previous speakers uh
so I don't think that this is the moment
but I always think it's very important
to keep the lines of communication open
to avoid you know massive escalation we
know that Russia possesses nuclear
weapons and what is patients with the
use of tactical nukes so I think it's
always important to sort of discuss uh
certain sort of red lines and make it
clear what is unacceptable for example
to the west but I think as you said you
know the chances of success at the
moment are not very uh likely
I really appreciate your Insight thank
you looking forward to talking to you in
the future
and thank you two for watching you can
see the program again anytime by
visiting our website Al jazeera.com for
further discussion go to our Facebook
page that's facebook.com forward slash
AJ Inside Story
you can also join the conversation on
Twitter our hunter is at AJ Inside Story
for me and the entire team here in Doha
bye for now
[Music]